[Musique]
il y à tous les ans 80 mille cas de
cancers de la peau dont 10 15 % sont des
mélanomes donc vraiment grave et c'est
un cancer qui est en nette progression
année après année du fait des
expositions au soleil
[Musique]
chaque année avec un capital plus ou
moins importants fonction de sa peau
mais si vous voulez quand on voit par
exemple des jeunes enfants de moins de
10 ans ou de moins ne de moins de 10 ans
par exemple qui effectivement sont
exposés au soleil on considère six ans
la peau claire qui sont en train de
gaspiller leur potentiel de résistance
aux au mélanome au carcinome et donc si
vous voulez il ya un gaspillage de ce
capital qui est dramatique ne pas
s'exposer systématiquement entre 12h et
16h face elle se serait la règle absolue
et surtout surtout alors prenez vos
responsabilités mais surtout pour les
enfants surtout pour les enfants les
jeunes enfants véritablement la crème
solaire
le chapeau le tee shirt etc il faut
penser à se protéger se protéger et
réitéré sa protection régulièrement ne
pas tenir compte du fait que robert
maintenant un bain de soleil ou où le
ciel est voilé
c'est pareil maintenant qu'il faut
véritablement le parfum une fois une
fois dans la journée simplement mélo
répété répété l'opération plusieurs fois
par jour